hi this is Sadashiva PI from science
mission today we have dr. Michael
Emanuel associate professor department
of micro for pharmacology from the
University of North Carolina at Chapel
Elise with us dr. Emanuel has won
several awards to his credit some of
them include 2.2 2007 outstanding
graduate student award from the
university of virginia 2008 to 2011
Damon Runyon postdoctoral fellowship
award 2013 UNC IBM junior faculty
development award 2013 to 2015
Jimmy V scholar award 2013 to 2016 Susan
G Komen courier catalyst award and 2019
to present American Cancer Society
research scholar grant award in addition
dr. Emmanuel has won has published
several research articles in prestigious
journals like cell-cell reports PNAS M
Bouc a JCB etc also here as the several
grants to his credit welcome dr. Emanuel
so let's start having some Q&A can you
please tell us about your background
education etc sure sure so I grew up in
the Northeast the United States in New
Jersey and with the college outside I
went to college in Pennsylvania and a
small school but now and from there I
was a I was a technician at the
University of Pennsylvania for a couple
of years before I went to graduate
school at the University of Virginia
where I looked in Todd's to converge lab
doing biochemistry and cell biology on
mechanisms of cell division I then when
did a postdoc in Boston at Harvard
Medical School and Steve elegies lab and
from there I was there for five or six
years and then I moved to the University
of North Carolina and started as an
assistant professor and
13 okay so you have been there since
last 60s almost almost exactly six years
yeah a little more okay and talk us
about talk was about puerile a black
people etc yeah so I have a small
medium-sized group I have three or four
students I have a technician who has
been with me since almost right after I
got here and at the moment I just have
one postdoctoral fellow so it's sort of
a small tight group very collaborative
okay and the research is like goes ups
and downs it has its own valleys and
troughs every now and then so how do you
motivate your students postdocs - yeah I
try to I think I think in a couple of
ways so so what I should say I'm I think
I'm generally a little hands off so I
try not to micromanage them but I think
the best way to keep them motivated is
to help their projects along it always
seems like at least it seemed like me
that you're always a little bit more
motivated to go in and do stuff when
everything seemed to be working and
clicking which is sort of the opposite
of what you need right so then yeah
nothing is working you don't go to work
at all yeah so helping them sort of work
through the little technical problems
that are hanging them up and then
keeping them encouraged and keeping
their eye on the big picture when things
are hard and then and then when things
are easy I think actually it's not it's
not that hard to motivate them so then
they they want to come in come in and
work their butts off so okay and like
how do you make them talk to us about
your mentoring philosophy yeah so how do
I mention them so so I make sure to talk
to them about their long medium and long
term goals mm-hmm early and then often
not often like in every meeting but we
meet regularly with the students I have
like a second
meeting once a week so that they don't
fall off what they're doing doesn't fall
off my radar so they don't get too
behind on something the postdocs I meet
with once every couple of weeks but then
I'm around a lot so there's a lot of
informal discussion I try to instill in
them to be independent so I think that
in the short term that can be harder but
in the long term it's much better it's
much better for me it's much better for
them and then we talk a lot about we try
to talk about what they want to do and
try not to shy away from those
conversations about career stuff or
what's influencing how they feel in the
lab that might not have to do with
experiments oh okay and the couple is
about your mentors like so you have any
mentors in your career yes I've been I
would say I've been really fortunate to
have many great mentors so when I
graduated from college I still wasn't
really that sure what I wanted to do and
I got a job doing working in a lab and
University of Pennsylvania in
Philadelphia and I honestly I moved to
Philadelphia because I had a friend that
was moving there and it had been not as
focused as maybe I should have been in
college and when I got in a lab I
realized I really loved research and I
really learned a lot from the woman I
worked for their name was Teresa Busch
she's still at UPenn and then I went to
graduate school and my primary mentor
Todd's to convert was fantastic he gave
me a very long leash but I was like a
really really really smart guy and I
learned like a lot talking to him and
also there was somebody in the lab next
door that worked on a similar problem
but in a different model system mm-hmm
and having that sort of like
complementary expertise topical
expertise on a similar problem was
really influential and then I went to do
a postdoc in Boston and Steve ologist
lab I'm Steve was also a fantastic
mentor he was incredibly supportive of
his people he gave us a lot of freedom
it was an exciting
place to be doing research there was a
was a big postdoc lab with 20 or 25 or
30 people at times and we were
surrounded by really smart people with a
really great leader who is really
supportive and protective of his people
and that was fantastic so and I think
I've taken things from all of these
different people and tried to
incorporate what I thought were the best
things that they did and then also what
works for me and doesn't work for me
based on my own personality okay I know
you had a busy person so you have a lot
of things going on in terms of research
and all those things I think around
second all so how do you spend your time
what are your hobbies other than what
you do in the lab yeah first I have two
little girls they've just turned five
and seven last week so I try to hang out
with them lots and lots especially in
the evenings and on the weekends
obviously we play together we ride bikes
together I really like riding bikes with
them and without them so I do a little
road cycling that's a little more
time-consuming so I don't do as much of
that as maybe I did when I didn't have
two kids but uh and for my other hobbies
I like to spend time with my wife and go
out we also I cook a little bit
so I cook at home I try to cook with the
girls and we try to eat his family and
stuff like that so we like making
homemade pizzas and spaghetti and
meatballs and these things that I
learned how to make growing up so I try
to do with them okay and coming back to
the lab stuff like talk to us about some
of the things different projects going
on in the lab and like you actually you
make and you can go on giving you a
presentation sure so as you'll see in my
presentation everything is a lab kind of
focuses on two broad related things and
that is the role of ubiquitin signaling
and cell cycle control so we're
interested in identifying the enzymes in
a big wooden pathway they contribute to
cell cycle
the mechanisms by which they do so
really are interested in identifying the
effectors of those enzymes so what are
the substrates of the ubiquitin ligases
and Deepa coordinating enzymes and how
does this kind of these different
pathways control not just normal cell
cycles but how might they be altered in
cancer cells and how does that
contribute to the kind of malignant
collaborations okay so and the how did
you get interested in this civil cell
cycle and the cancer stuff
yeah so when I was a graduate student I
worked on cell division I worked on
mitosis and I worked on these large
protein complexes called the kinetochore
which control chromosome movements
during mitosis and then when I was a
postdoc most of what I did was we did I
did a lot of technology development and
a lot of screening and this was targeted
identifying in a large-scale way
substrates in the ubiquitin pathway and
when it can we were working on specific
substrates I ended up focusing on the
stuff I already know a little bit about
which was things involved in cell
division and when I started my own lab
at UNC I had had identified a number of
substrates in the cell cycle that seemed
like they were right for analysis or
maybe low-hanging fruit and so I went
after interrogating those and my lab
ended up sort of I don't know
bifurcating into studying sort of g1s
control and g2m control through the
ubiquitin pathway so but it happened but
I would say very organically you know I
look back at the the proposal I wrote
and what I was going to do in my own lab
and some of their hints of some things
in there that I ended up doing but a lot
of it sort of grew out of what was most
exciting what really took off and once
we got here okay so you can go ahead and
present your work on the cell cycle
great let me pull up my presentation
keep our fingers crossed that it works
yep all right you can let me just make
sure everything is good okay yeah
everything looks good yep okay well
thank you for having me here today and
I'm going to tell you about a little bit
of my labs work on ubiquitin signaling
and cell cycle in cancer and if this
runs too long please let me know and
stop me I'm like no problem
okay so again my interest here drives
from my work first starting as a
graduate student where I worked on cell
division and specifically mitosis in
fact this is a photo micrograph here I
made of a mitotic spindle assembled in
frog extracts maybe more years ago than
I'd like to admit
and this dovetailed with my interest in
the ubiquitin pathway where as a postdoc
I looked using large-scale systems based
technologies to identify substrates
using a fact-based genetic approach and
also proteomic assays that we and others
had developed and this allowed us to
connect enzymes and substrates or
phenotypes and substrates and now my lab
kind of worked at the interface here
working at trying to understand what are
the substrates and the ubiquitin pathway
involved in cell cycle and also what are
the enzymes okay so this is a very brief
overview of the ubiquitin system at the
Cascade of three enzymes termed e1 e2
and e3 and what this ultimately does is
culminate in the conjugation of
ubiquitin onto substrate proteins and
really the the key enzymes here that
ubiquitin ligases as you can see I put
the approximately the number of these in
human cells below each of them I'm not
sure if you can see my pointer or not
yeah we can see that point where there's
almost 600 cubic four in ligases or more
in human cells and these are what
determine which substrates get
ubiquitinated in ubiquitination can have
diverse outcomes so you can form all of
these different types of ubiquitin
linkages and with these different
linkages indicate is that the ubiquitin
molecule which is actually itself
approach
and has a number of lysine residues in
it
these ubiquitin are connected to each
other through those different license
and ubiquitin so for example these k 48
linked to ubiquitin chains these are
connected through lysine 48 ubiquitin
itself whereas k 11 or k 63 link chains
are linked through k 11 or 63 in life
and ubiquitin respectively so these
different structures look different to
the cell so they impart different
physiologic outcomes and the ones people
probably are most familiar with are
these over here because these are really
important in protein degradation in fact
this k 48 linked protein degradation
pathway has been the most well studied
aspect to be a big word in pathway but
we also know there are these other
linkages like k 63 okay 29 link chains
as well as others or multi
ubiquitination x' this is the addition
of multiple mono ubiquitination for
money a bit more donations alone which
can impart significant changes in cell
signaling but it's this aspect over here
protein degradation that I'm really
going to focus on today there's also a
large number of enzyme another class of
enzymes in the ubiquitin pathway called
diva quitin aces or dubs there's roughly
a hundred of these in human cells and
they're broken down into distinct
categories but what these these do is
catalyze the removal of ubiquitin from
substrates so they remove ubiquitin and
as you can imagine at least for the case
of degradation targeted ubiquitination
these are going to lead in many cases to
increases in substrates so by
antagonizing the activity of the
ubiquitin ligase they do ubiquitinated
substrates and they often stabilize
proteins that they target okay so the
ubiquitin pathway controls a number of
cell cycle proteins so I'm showing you
perhaps the wels most well known ones
here these are the Cyclones
so as many of you know cyclin D e a and
B represent key regulators of cell cycle
progression and they do this by pairing
with a cyclin dependent kinase and while
the cyclin dependent kinase is don't
oscillate during the cell cycle the
Cyclones do and they do this by changes
in their transcription
I'm pointing to here for example for
cyclin b which is upregulated in g2
phase of the cell cycle its abundance
increases their transcription and then
this sharp decrease as you see here is
controlled by its ubiquity nation and
degradation however it's not just the
cyclones that cycle there's actually
hundreds if not thousands of genes and
proteins that go up and down during the
cell cycle so this is a transcriptional
profiling experiment one of the first
that was done on the cell cycle by
someone named Mike Whitfield who's
actually a former graduate student from
UVA so I like to show this one and what
you're seeing here is many many many
genes going up and down and up and down
as cells go through the cell cycle and
not only are the gene cell cycle
regulated but there's many proteins that
are cell cycle regulated so this is a
proteomic study that was done by Tony
Lee when he was a postdoctoral fellow
and we collaborated with him on this
work to show that where he really showed
that there's hundreds of proteins at the
protein level that are also going up and
down during cell cycle progression and
all of these ones actually that would
point to down here are in fact
ubiquitinated and degraded as cells go
through the cell cycle so we know that
accurate protein degradation plays
important roles in both the order timing
and irreversibility of the cell cycle
it's critical to maintain genome
integrity and we know that there's
hundreds if not thousands of proteins
that are actually oscillating during
every cell cycle and if you think that
there's probably 10 to 12 thousand genes
or proteins expressed in any given cell
line or cell type this this uh this
actually signifies a really enormous
remodeling about the genome and the
proteome during every cell cycle we also
know that the ubiquitin pathway is vital
to human health and that it's
dysfunctional a number of diseases this
includes both neurological diseases as
well as cancer where we know that the
the degradation of a number of proteins
is also altered for example p53 see Mik
the hypoxia-inducible factor hit and rf2
which is an oxidative response
transcription factor we also know that
there's many ubiquitinated enzymes that
is components in the ubiquitin pathway
that are altered in disease and for
example if you look in the basal like
subtype of breast cancer this is very
similar to the triple negative type of
breast cancer which is a very tough to
treat form of the disease excuse me
you see there's very few mutations
outside of mutation of p53 but instead
there are actually these huge copy
number changes and these recurring copy
number changes you see here
amplification of 1q for example or
amplification of 8q or the macaca gene
is we think these really are important
contributors to disease and what these
do is they change and destabilize the
dosage of a number of genes you're
ending up in trouble ubiquitin pathway
so the first part of that what i'm going
to tell you about today revolves around
an e3 ubiquitin ligase or at least
starts with an e3 ubiquitin ligase
called the anaphase promoting complex or
cycle is ohm or the AP CC and this is a
critical III ligase that mediates the
mitosis to g1 transition so it becomes
activated at the metaphase to anaphase
transition it quite literally promotes
anaphase as its name suggests and then
it remains on all through g1 phase
actually it has to be shut off before
the start of S phase this enzyme comes
in two flavors APC CVC 20 and cdh1
and these are the the subunits in the
complex that switch out and which
designate specific substrates for
ubiquitination and the importance of
this complex in cell cycle control is
really belied by the fact that it
controls a number of key cell cycle
regulators for ubiquitination and
degradation this can includes mitotic
cyclins a and B proteins from Bob and
sister chromatid cohesion DNA
replication as well as the mitotic
spindle and importantly it targets these
proteins for degradation using these
non-canonical ubiquitin chains these K
11 link ubiquitin chains which are
important for protein degradation the
APC is also important in cancer biology
we think so this is from a recent TCGA
study looking at roughly a thousand
genes the ubiquitin path
'we looking at either hotspot mutations
or loss-of-function mutations you can
see over here in the loss-of-function
mutations there's ubiquitin ligases like
VHL this is the font but wind out tumor
suppressor or an F 43 and bap1 which is
the D ubiquitin a C's are all
well-established
having roles in cancer and you can see
this protein cdh1 this is the
coactivator for the APC here is one of
the most frequently the genes most
frequently observed to have a
loss-of-function mutation so APC we know
is important and normal as well as
cancer cell cycles and we think it's
implicated in tumor suppression we know
that APC in mice is a hypo insufficient
tumor suppressor that is you lose a
single allele and the mouse
spontaneously form tumors we also know
from a number a number of model systems
that it collaborates with RB to restate
restrain caliber a proliferation and
finally cdh1 we know can be inactivated
by the pi3 kinase Akt pathway and this
is work recent work from my own lab so
like the cyclin-cdk complexes which
drive cell cycle the APC together with
Chieko activators have really analogous
regulatory mechanisms so we know that
both are controlled by cofactor
dependent activation so CDKs are
activated by cyclones
whereas APC is activated by these
co-activators GDC 20 and cdh1
both are regulated by phosphorylation
they both can be bound by inhibitors
which turned them off both are
inactivated as well by cofactor
dependent degradation so the cofactors
of APC these protein CDC 20 and cdh1
both get degraded and a cell cycle
dependent matter much like the psyche
ones and finally we know that the cyclin
CDK s are controlled by p TM
reversibility that is the post
translator post translational
modifications the phosphorylations they
add two substrates can be reversed
whoever was not clear that this was
actually also true for the APC so in d
ubiquitin ace that would remove
ubiquitin from APC substrates and not
yet been identified so i'm going to tell
you about two stories one is the role of
a dub and regulating mitosis and
restraining APC and second I'll tell you
about
a dub that controls cell cycle
transcription at the end I'll tell you
how we think this is why we think these
two diva coordination are important in
cancer biology so as I alluded to before
the APC really prefers to make these
caleb and linked ubiquitin chains on
substrates and you can see this here in
a cell cycle synchronization experiment
where cells have been released from the
g1/s boundary and as they go through the
cell cycle and come into mitosis which
is mark right here with us focused own
age 3 you can see there's this huge
increase in K 11 linked ubiquitination
so we reasoned that if we want to define
a divakaran age that antagonize these K
11 link to pick wooden chains or open a
antagonize the APC it should have some
specificity for K 11 link ubiquitination
and this kind is interested in that do
you before Denise called saison or ot
ud7 B this is an ovarian tumor family
dub that had been reported to have
specificity for very particular types of
ubiquitin chains namely these tail 11
chains
although other reports that suggested
may be specificity for K 48 or k63
chains and this prompt us to prompted us
to take a look at this more carefully so
what we did is we purified saison from
bacteria and we mixed it with either K
11 linked K 48 linked or k63 linked dye
ubiquitin probes and what we're looking
for here is the the conversion of value
according to mono ubiquitination as a
readout for saison activity and you can
see in these first few lanes saison is d
bic winning deva coordinating these
Caleb and Link probes whereas the K 48
k63 link probes are completely resistant
to de Vaca donation and this really
argued that saison is very highly
specific for K Elevens
although their reports came out what we
were doing this work that indicated that
dubs could swish switch their
selectivity
based on post translational
modifications that would happen in cells
so we isolated saison from human cells
and did the same thing and you can see
here again this is a full-length saison
coming out of 293 T cells you can see it
prefers K 11 link chains whereas it
really doesn't do anything to these
other ubiquitin linkages
so this slide is to remind me that
basically everything surrounding the APC
is cell cycle regulated so it's
co-activators or cell cycle regulated
it's twos or cell cycle regulated and
it's all of its substrates are
essentially cell cycle regulated so we
look to see if Cezanne was also cell
cycle regulated here we're taking you to
West cells we're putting them in mitosis
using a microtubule poison called
Mikado's all you can see compared to a
synchronous cells it's significantly
elevated and then it's levels come back
down as the cells go back into g1 in S
phase
same is true in HCT 1/16 cells and also
in our p1 cell as you can see these
cells are blocked in g0 using serum
deprivation and in relation to the cell
cycle and again saison levels peak as
cells get into mitosis we can all we saw
the exact same thing when we immuno
stains with the immunofluorescent
antibody you can see in mycotic cells
compared to an interface cell saison
levels are really really quite high and
we know these cells are my toast is
based on the morphology of the mitotic
spindle when we quantify this it's about
a seven to ten fold increase in saison
and mitotic versus non mitotic cells so
saison could also bind to a PC substrate
so here we are introducing saison into
cells together with three well
characterized APC substrates box m1
Aurora a and cyclin b and we IP saison
you can see in each case the APC
substrate comes down here here in here
so that so what we know now is saison
disassembles the types of ubiquitin
linkages the APC makes its up regulated
at the same time the APC is active and
it also binds to their substrates and we
can recapitulate this binding in vitro
using recombinant proteins which I'm not
going to show you so I am going to show
you sorry so here we are mixing saison
with either cyclin b or over a you can
see it combined to these proteins in
vitro in the absence of ubiquitination
so we have a deep inner nature to bind
substrates it's up regulated in mitosis
and prefers the types of ubiquitin
change the APC a special
to create so this suggested to us the
question does Cezanne actually
antagonize a PC substrate elimination to
address this question we collaborated
with a new investigator here at UNC NIC
Brown in the Department of Pharmacology
and he'd develop a system where you
could purify this entire APC complex
which is 1.2 mega Dolan's in size from
insect cells it's allowed us to make
k-11 link chains on model substrates and
then we can mix it with saison to see
what happened so here is that
ubiquitinated in this case cyclin b you
can see it gets nicely ubiquitinated in
vitro when we add saison to this
reaction you can see there's d
ubiquitination of the substrate so these
bands here go away and actually this
band at the bottom you can see gets
darker because these are collapsing into
it whereas if we use a catalytically
dead version of saison for the catalytic
systems mutated you can see these new
bikal donations are maintained and
because we were doing this in vitro we
could sort of play with this in either
form k 48 or k63 link chains on
substrates which are not how they would
normally be decorated but in both of
these cases we can see that saison
actually doesn't do anything so it's
only restraining K 11 link you bit
bitter Nations but not K 48 or k63 link
ubiquitin Nations and this really
suggests that says I'm specifically D
ubiquitin 8 scale 11 chains on
substrates we next wanted to know if it
actually control substrate degradation
so to do this we synchronized cells in
mitosis either with and without saison
which we've depleted by RNA I and then
we analyzed the kinetics of substrate
degradation using a Western blot you can
see here I'm showing you Aurora a and
fox in one and in both cases you can see
a one in two hours and three hours then
in the art saison RNA I treated cells
these substrates go way more quickly
compared to controls we did something
similar in asynchronous cells where we
take cells that are expressing a
fluorescently tagged cyclin b now we
don't have to treat them with any drugs
we just image them going through mitosis
and we look at either controller saison
it sells when we do this I'm showing you
a representative self here you can see
this saison depleted cells degrade
cycling be more quickly than our control
depleted cells cells trigger with a an
SN a targeting Firefly luciferase I
think they may be the caveat of both of
these experiments is that if you did
something upstream to make mitosis go
faster you might see this as an indirect
effect and to address this concern we
developed developed a cell extract
system we've put cells in g1 when the
APC is very active
we made cell extract so now we have a
lysate in a tube we're not too worried
about it going through the cell cycle or
not we can just monitor substrate
degradation in vitro in a test tube and
you can see here these q1 extracts
rapidly and robustly degrade cyclin b
and if you add saison to them it impairs
cyclin b decoration we see the same
thing with another well-behaved
substrate or or a so array gets degraded
very rapidly in these extracts and again
this is happening in a water bath not in
cells so we don't have to worry about
really cell cycle progression and we can
largely block this by adding saison and
what I'm not showing you is that this of
course depends on its catalytic activity
finally we found that saison actually
prevents the formation of Mike from
nuclei so when we deplete saison and
look at cells under a microscope we see
these very nice micro nuclei forming and
importantly these micro nuclei are this
formation of these mark nuclei which is
increased about threefold is completely
dependent on this other protein ub to us
and ub to us is actually the e to you've
been putting conjugating enzyme APC uses
to form k-11 linked to footprint chains
so this suggests that saison is doing
something to promote genome stability to
prevent the formation of these micro
nuclei in cells and it's all dependent
on a PC so we reasoned that the easiest
way to form these micro nuclei would be
through chromosome segregation errors so
we went back and looked in mitotic cells
and what you can see here here's a
control cell treated with again a
controller an AI there's a metaphase
align cell the chromosomes
purple in the mitotic spindle is shown
in green here's a cell in anaphase 2
very nicely separated masses of
chromatin whereas in the Cezanne
depleted so as you can see we
occasionally see these misaligned
chromosomes we also see these
chromosomes that are kind of stalled in
the mids own an anaphase and that are
missed segregating here and here and
these we think are what are leading to
the formation of those micro nuclei I
showed you on the previous slide and
like I previously showed you this is
still all dependent on ube 2's so if we
deplete UB to us I completely get rid of
this two to threefold increase we see in
chromosome segregation errors so what
I've told you so far is that saison
antagonizes the APC so we've shown you I
showed you data that prefers k-11 chains
that it sells like a regulated it binds
to a PC substrates and do ubiquitin h
them in vitro and regulates a PC
substrate degradation in a variety of
different assays and it gives phenotypes
that are consistent with antagonizing a
PC so we think that this is a potential
pathway by which a PC is antagonized and
I'll tell you why I think this is
important in cancer a few slides but
Cezanne as I'll show you later is
regulated in some diseases and it D
Vikrant ABC's Kalyn and link chains
formed by HPC and this goes together
with other pathways which we think lead
to a PC and activation in cancer so for
example we recently showed that there's
a proteolytic pathway that leads to cdh1
degradation which is also going to
effectively inactivate the APC and the
upstream driver of this pathway is in
fact the pi3 kinase Akt cascade so in
the second part here I'm going to tell
you about cell cycle transcriptional
control by dubs so excuse me we talked a
little bit about getting out of mitosis
now we're gonna talk about getting into
mitosis and the key regulator or getting
into mitosis
one of the key regulators is this
transcription factor called Fox m1 Fox
and one in fact Leeds triggers the
accumulation of a number of those
proteins that are involved in mitotic
progression including a number of APC
substrates and thought someone as you
might expect both its activity and also
its abundance or cell cycle regulated so
this was looking at a fox in one
reporter and a paper that's now six or
seven years old from gavin grant and you
can see he's like me to collect some one
reporter during cell cycle progression
and the activity of fox and one goes up
and down and up and down box and one is
also extremely important in cancer so
it's highly up regulated based on its
transcriptional signature in both
basal-like breast which is the again
similar to triple negative breast cancer
as well as high-grade serous ovarian
cancer these are two very genetically
similar diseases and we know that fox
and one is activated because we see
increases in its transcriptional program
related to cell cycle as well as a
number of genes that are involved in DNA
damage repair in our own analysis we see
that as fox am one expression increases
the proliferation score the tumor
increases so this is looking at more
than a thousand tumors that were
analyzed by the TCGA is the Cancer
Genome Atlas you can see these are
different subtypes of breast cancer
luminal a and B these largely correspond
to the hormone receptor-positive type of
disease or to positive and then basal
and which again is very similar to the
triple negative type and you can see his
thoughts on what expression goes up it's
probably the proliferation score the
tumor goes up and this is true not just
in that some subtypes are higher than
others but even within subtypes have you
look at these luminal a and B tumors
there's a really nice correlation
between the expression of Fox and one
and proliferation score as you would
expect his thoughts and one expression
goes up as as the expression of its
targets some of which we've already
talked about Cobra a and cyclin B so we
knew that Fox and one was controlled by
ubiquitination in fact my lab had
recently identified a ubiquitin ligase
that controlled but someone destruction
and we we wondered or ourselves if Fox
and one thought someone might also be
controlled by divakaran aces and we were
curious to identify this for a variety
of reasons one we thought we'd learn
something about how normal cell cycles
are controlled we reason that since
there are a number of cancers or the
flux and one signature is up but the
protein does not appear to be up or the
mRNA does not appear to be up then maybe
there were divakaran aces which
stabilized the protein thereby
increasing its levels and finally
because dubs are catalytic proteases we
reason that perhaps in the future you
could target Fox m1 by inhibiting a diva
quitin ace that promoted its stability
thereby kind of reversing this direct
reaction and leading to its degradation
I already settle that so we asked a very
simple question is fought someone
actively regulated by two ubiquitin aces
so we took kind of cell lines we have
lying around the lab we added app and of
inhibitor this is a pretty toxic
molecule that inactivates most of the
cysteine protease paystubs all
simultaneously and what we see is within
a couple of hours fox and one is
decorated in all of these cell lines in
a dose-dependent matter this motivated
us to actually do an SI RNAi screen to
look for the doublet controls box m1 we
found one that reproducibly led to a
decrease in fox in one level as this
stuff is called us p21 and you can see
here when we deplete USB 21 fought
someone is almost completely completely
gone just to make sure this wasn't some
peculiarity of this si RNA pool we broke
the pool apart you can see if we deplete
USB 21 with a bunch of different
reagents in this case three different
RNA reagents all of them lead to a
reduction in thought some hormones
in addition to the the loss-of-function
experiment we also did the
gain-of-function experiments over here
we're over expressing USP 21 you can see
it up regulates endogenous Fox m1 you
can see that right here likewise if we
look at exhaustion ously expressed Fox
m1 so this is fought someone expressed
off a heterologous promoter you can see
it also significantly increases the
exogenously expressed Fox m1 so we know
that this increase now is not due to
just some increase general increase in
transcription and we've confirmed that
by cure our DQ PCR next we wanted to
determine if USP 21 controls Fox and one
stability we do this using what we call
a cycloheximide chase experiment so we
either treat cells with a control RNA I
or with one targeting USP 21 which is
going to pleat it and then we treat
cells with cycloheximide which shuts off
all translation and we analyze the decay
of substrates you can see here we're
doing this in a triple negative breast
cancer cell line when we deplete USP 21
Fox and one levels our half-life is much
shorter so it's half-life goes from 11
or 12 hours to just about 4 hours we've
done the reverse experiment where we
overexpress this and we get the reverse
or result and that also is dependent on
the catalytic activity so next we wanted
to ask whether or not USP 21 in fact
binds to Fox m1 since it seems to
regulate it in the appropriate
directions which would indicate [ __ ]
someone is a substrate so we can detect
an interaction between these proteins by
Co IP when they're both transfected into
cells we did detect an interaction at
the endogenous level where we are IP and
USP 21 with a specific antibody you can
see this pulls out Fox and one in
addition to us p21 and finally in maybe
most convincingly we've produced both of
these proteins and bacteria so there's
no other confounding effects we isolate
them individually we then put them in a
test tube together and you can see they
still interact with one another
and this bloody thing cleanse
considerable weight to the idea that USP
21 is binding and deep it coordinating
pots in one to test this a little more
carefully we look at Fox and one
ubiquitination so to do this we're
introducing histidine tag ubiquitin into
cells were then recovering it on nickel
agarose and then blotting for endogenous
proteins in this case we're blending for
Fox and one so you can see Fox I'm one
is ubiquitinated this is indicated by
this smear which is due to the fact that
many many many ubiquitous have been
added to [ __ ] someone if we could Co
introduce or if we introduced us p21
into cells you can see it's almost
completely deevak grenaded and this is
again dependent on the catalytic
activity of this enzyme because if we
had a c2 21 a this is a catalytically
dead version of USP 21 and now it
doesn't do you bit marinate it so all of
this suggested to us that us p21
controlled Fox and one is a substrate so
we wanted to know it does actually USB
21 contribute to Fox in one biology we
started by looking at Fox and one target
genes we found them when we deplete USB
21 like when we deplete Fox and one you
see a reduction in the expression of Fox
and one target genes like Aurora a
cyclin b cdk1
and polo kinase this indicated there
might be a defect in cell cycle
progression since these are genes that
are really important in progression
towards mitosis so this was one of these
slides where I really summarized many
many months worth of work from a
graduate student unfortunately in a
single graph but what he did is he
developed the protocol again in triple
negative breast cancer cells where he
gives synchronized cells at the g1/s
boundary and then he would after doing
RNA i to these different genes and then
he'd monitored the time it took for them
to get to mitosis so he blocked him at
g1 s and then released them he'd
released them into a drug that would
then trap them in mitosis so we could
look kind of the cumulative number of
cells that got into m phase during the
experiment you can see the control cells
which are here in black about 40 to 50
percent of them and
mitosis by the end of the experiment if
we deplete Fox m1 which is here orange
you can see there's a severe reduction
and the ability of cells to progress
into mitosis we see something very very
similar when we deplete USB 21 again and
a little bit better but not a lot better
this is consistent with the fact that
there is a little bit of Fox in one left
when we complete USP 21 and finally if
we deplete USB 21 but then X force the
expression of Fox someone using a cDNA
on top of that we can completely rescue
Fox on one levels and you can see we get
a partial rescue in the in progression
towards mitosis and what this suggests
to us is that Fox and one is a critical
substrate of USB 21 in controlling cell
cycle progression but it's likely not
the only substrate we've done this
experiment many many times we never get
a full rescue we think that really
argues that there are other substrates
of USB 21 that might be involved in cell
cycle control since Fox m1 makes the is
involved in the expression of all of
these genes and proteins that are
involved in mitosis specifically we
asked if USB 21 depletion which
sensitize cells to tax also taxol is an
anti mitotic microtubule targeting drug
that's used clinically as paclitaxel to
treat a variety of cancers and
specifically to treat triple negative
breast cancers where Fox and one
activity is very high and you can see in
these four different cell lines if we
complete either Fox in one or us p21 the
cells are sensitized to tax all
treatment and moreover if we take a cell
line as selling that we can use as a
xenograph these some 149 cells which are
inherently very resistant to tax all we
can analyze whether or not us p12 us p21
plays a role in tactile sensitivity in
in an animal so when we do this you can
see in cells where we be they're not
depleted anything or where we just
treated with tax all you can see they
grow as well as the
trol tumors which are the black line
whereas if we deplete us p21 and dose
with paclitaxel together you can clean
round we've got a nice tumor growth so I
think all of this sort of points to a
role for us b21 controlling fox and
water being important and at least
cancer in culture and perhaps in
Mattie's we wanted to know if this how
these observations extended into into
humans
so does us p21 actually contribute to
plot someone activation in human cancer
so we were fortunate that Fox and one
was recently added to the list of
proteins which are being analyzed by the
Cancer Genome Atlas using reverse phase
protein arrays or rppa and I sort of
have an overview of the rppa platform
but suffice it to say what we're looking
at is the relative amount of protein in
different tumors so we could say because
we can analyze because we know which
tumors have high levels of us p21 and
which ones do not we can say in cancer
for us p21 is amplified are
overexpressed is Fox and one changing
and how is it changed relative to all of
the other proteins the other two or 300
proteins analyzed by our PPA
remarkably when we did this analysis
each of these little dots is one of the
proteins that's regulated or analyzed by
the rppa analysis you can see actually
the most statistically significant
change in a positive direction in tumors
with high high us p21 excuse me is Fox
m1 which is I think like almost too much
for us to actually believe and you can
see these other genes down here cyclin b
and m sh6 for example these are fox and
one targets a SNS is also involved in
breast tumor proliferation there's other
gene a dar one is on the same chromosome
as us p21 providing a really nice
positive control and you can see we see
if we look in cell lines we see
basically the same thing reflected so
these cell lines i've marked in red here
are basil white breast
answers and you can see again where USP
21 is up you're here here this is where
Fox m1 is up so if we go back to the
genomics data and look to see where we
caught us B 21 is upregulated for
example by copy number amplification
what is the proliferation score you can
see the proliferation score again like
when fox and one is increased when you
ESPE 21 is increased proliferation score
of the tumor goes up and we see this
strong enrichment for a proliferation
signature in the USP 21 hi tumors and so
if we look at this is data now from the
C bio portal looking at roughly a
thousand different breast tumors each of
these little gray lines is a different
patient wherever you see orange or
excuse me pink or red this is a tumor
where USB 21 is either amplified or up
regulated you can see so remarkable 40
percent of breast tumors for us B 21 is
upregulated and I put this again paracin
to micchan cyclin D these are
well-established oncogenes which are not
up regulated to nearly the same extent
interestingly we notice that stays on
the dub I told you about for the first
half of this talk is similarly up
regulated in the same breast tumors and
if we look at progression-free survival
you can see there's a negative
correlation by between either saison
which I'm showing you here or us p21 and
progression in disease-free survival in
patients this is patients with breast
cancer in fact if we look at all the d
bic return aces in breast cancer this is
each of these little dots is at
different dub we're looking at their
amplification or overexpression
frequency two of the three most highly
up regulated d bic win and aces are us
p21 the double have been talking about
for the last 15 or so minutes and stays
on this is the dub I talked to you about
in the beginning this was actually
really remarkable these were two
different people in the lab we've come
upon these two dogs by completely
orthogonal approaches one we were very
specifically focused on a DV I put an
ace for Fox m1 this is a transcription
factor up regulated
as I told you in Basel like triple
negative breast cancers involved in cell
cycle and proliferation the other one we
came to because we were interested in a
dub that was antagonized as a pc
different in lyday's which were
interested in because it's a key cell
cycle regulator the reason these are to
both highly amplified and overexpressed
is that they're actually co-localize on
the same chromosome so both of them are
at 1q 21 to 22 this is one of the the
biggest amplicons and all of breast
cancers specifically in triple negative
breast cancers the other major
amplification region is this region 8q
which you can see here this is where the
macaca gene is so we know why we see
these high-level amplifications here and
while this almost this whole chromosome
arm is amplified out here and not just
in breast cancer but also in other
cancers like kidney cancer for example
we see large amplifications of 1q and
upregulation of us p21 and saison
there's no clear oncogenic driver here
there's no Mik like Olga gene here so it
suggests the possibility that the
amplification of these two things is
remodeling the protein landscape in
contributing to cancer cell
proliferation do the mechanisms I
described or perhaps through other
substrates
alright so to summarize what I've told
you about the last 40 minutes or so if
we just talk about exactly what the data
says what I told you about is a deep if
elimination vault in mitosis this is a
dub called saison or otu d7 b which
antagonizes the APC ubiquitin ligase and
then the second half i told you about a
second dub called us p21 and then a dia
bik remains box-and-one is involved in
g2 and progression through cell cycle
transcription and I told you at the very
end there how about how they're both of
these proteins are both of these genes
excuse me or Co amplified and breast
cancer by virtue of the fact that
they're located right next to each other
on the same chromosome and I think we
take like a step back as to what the
kind of more interesting implications of
this is is one that suggests that the
also altered dosage or the altered
expression or copy number changes in
ubiquitin pathway components
is likely to promote cancer phenotypes
the ones I talked about today are cells
like own proliferation but you can
imagine other enzymes in these pathways
which are dysregulated through changes
in their expression which are going to
change the expression of other things
that lead to these phenotypes so we
think these changes are going to likely
ripple through cancer Caribbeans and
reshape them through changes in
proteolysis and protein degradation and
that these changes importantly are
invisible to genomic interrogation and
to really understand how these changes
contribute to disease phenotypes or to
cell phenotypes really requires more
complex approaches perhaps proteomics or
genetic approaches that which get it
proteins instead of just our mRNAs and
finally the last take-home I think is
that perhaps in the future inhibiting
specific dubs would represent a
potential future therapy for treating
malignancy and these sorts of things
already beginning to be explored for one
dove in particular USP 7 which is
upstream in the p53 pathway and recently
a lot of work has been done to make
inhibitors to us b7 and perhaps drugging
other dubs in the future will be a real
viable alternative to current therapies
like chemotherapy so finally I just want
to thank the people that did the work
so Thomas Bonacci is a postdoc in the
lab he did all of the work in the first
half one stays on Anthony RCC who
actually just defended his PhD last week
and will be leaving the lab in a month
or two he did all of the work on say on
USP 21 excuse me and they were we have a
small group so I think there's everybody
is supporting everybody a lot of help
came from Qin Shi Huang was my
technician and lab manager who helps out
with basically everything Jen Ali Raj
and Taylor are all students are former
student postdocs in the lab that
contributed to these projects as well in
particular here's our collaborators I'd
like to thank Nick Brown who helped us
with the APC assays and who with who we
continue to continue to collaborate with
especially with this student Raquel
aussie suzuki who's a former postdoc
here at unc and now is that the
university of wisconsin helped it for
some of those nice imaging experiments
gavin grandjean cook helped us with the
live cell imaging of saison substrates
pained Nathalie Chuck Chris Katie and
Dan helped with a variety of projects in
which I did not have time to talk about
aloe Katie and her lab helped with some
of the computational analysis I told you
about so here's our funding right now
from NIGMS in the American Cancer
Society and you see RF and formerly from
the V Foundation and Susan G Komen and
with that I'd be happy to take any
questions okay thank you so much it's a
really interesting so I've been hearing
about you can just get out of the yeah
so thank you very much it's a pretty
interesting presentation so I really
liked it so I have a couple of questions
we have a few minutes yeah sure one of
them being it's a general I don't know
it's a maybe a silly question
like you mentioned initially in the
first slides like dizzy ubiquitin Asus
like our DNA ubiquity nurses they act on
the lysine right there ubiquity Nate
lysine
yeah and Kate Levin and all those things
48 and all those different residues on
different proteins so and there are some
mono ubiquity Nessus also like which
just put one ubiquity is there is there
a like I don't know about this field
much so is there any like these proteins
is there a number of ubiquity in they
put on each of this protein is there a
specification or they need to put in for
six or one two
so for different III ubiquitin ligases
will or eat you together with their
issues determine what the change look
like or whether or not it's like a mono
ubiquitination and how how the enzymes
decide whether they're going to add one
or say a wah
is not really well known and I think
most people would say they they do one
of two things they either add one or
they add a bunch but but if there is
more specificity in between one and a
lot we don't really know we don't
actually know in most cases how the
enzymes determine whether or not they're
going to do it we know which parts of
them do it so for in many cases the e2
ubiquitin conjugating enzymes are the
ones determining it but mechanistically
how it all is put together is not super
well understood so it is understood to
some degree how the different linkages
are chosen so for example the APC makes
k-11 chains and those are determined by
the specific e to s it uses and if you
force it to use different e2 is it will
not make a lemon chains anymore
and which lysine need to does it also
depends is it known like okay only one
because protein has several license
right oh yeah this is this is actually
so from mono ubiquitination which we
don't really work on but there it's like
it's almost like a phosphorylation site
there's a very specific residue that
gets modified
whereas prepolymer coordination the the
enzyme at the enzyme is this hand will
hold the substrate like this and then
modification is going to say happen like
over here and kind of any ubiquitin
that's over there will get modified and
as you search it people try to mutate
specific lysines to block ubiquitination
it often is very difficult because the
enzyme doesn't have a lot of preference
for a specific lysine residue whereas
like a kinase does for example so the
specificity lies elsewhere in the
binding site but not in the the residue
that gets modified does it to the
conformation of the protein also is a
play role like okay is it open or not
and all those is a really good question
so I think in most cases we don't know
our lab actually has a different project
that suggests there's a there's a
substrate of a specific e3 that perhaps
undergoes a conformational allosteric
change
and that enhances or inhibits its
ubiquitination but this is really sort
of preliminary and not that well worked
out yet yeah one of the reasons I was
asking about ubiquitous and poly like
that is in brains like you have the poly
glue termination here is a fibrils and
all those things so I was just thinking
okay this ubiquitination has anything to
do with the way like number of ubiquity
an added does it depend like I mean like
one is the why and how also like okay if
there are more ubiquity in on particular
protein does it is active more or
something like that it's just a kind of
throwing of the kind of whatever is yes
in some of those diseases especially
there's neurological diseases we have
those like kind of like plaques and
stuff like that
you never they can be like packed full
of ubiquitin and actually there's a
almost certainly or not almost really
there's definitely defects and ubiquitin
proteasome pathway funk I didn't yeah
diseases so that contributing to
pathology okay and the regarding you
order yes p21 is there any like mouse
model or anything knockout or anything
is Binda so I don't know about USB 21
mile people have not got saison when we
worked out worked out in the beginning
the first part and those mice are
basically okay and I think that's
interesting because it suggests that you
really could potentially drug USB 21 and
that could be therapeutically
advantageous and maybe not too toxic to
patients so although that really remains
to be seen in humans but okay and
finally like one of the questions last
question would be like you mentioned
that initially there are lots of these
ubiquitin aces in the system like DHS so
like is there a likely talk about cancer
and there are only a couple of them like
you show up like yes p21 season and all
those are very high so is there is
redundancy in terms of the human cell
like okay
ESP is not there I'll go with the other
one
them so it's really hard to know I don't
think we know enough about the Dubs to
say there are certainly enzymes that are
controlled by multiple dubs like there
are enzymes that are controlled by
multiple or there are sub trees that are
controlled by multiple dubs in the same
way there are substrates that are
controlled by multiple ubiquitin ligases
or that are phosphorylated by multiple
kinase is so yeah we just don't know
enough about how much redundancy there
is and I think this has been a little
bit murky by the fact that outside of
the cell these dubs are actually quite
lousy and that they are a little
nonspecific whereas inside the cell that
seems like they have remarkable specimen
specificity at least in our hands and
why that is is not so clear okay so Mike
thank you so much I really appreciate
it's it's a really pretty very nice talk
so I really enjoyed it learned a little
bit more on what I knew already so thank
you very much you're like are you open
to taking grad students or postdoc
anything because I'm going to put your
email and contact information out there
so can I say later if you are interested
in knowing more about the subject or in
any positions you can contact my way all
of our graduate students here come
through the UNC umbrella program okay so
if students are interested in that I
would direct them to the unc PSP which
is the biomedical and biological
biological biomedical graduate student
of the program something like that unz
be BSP okay but yet there are people out
there looking for postdocs they should
contact me for sure okay so thank you so
much again so us will be like within
next 24 hours it will be on our website
I'll send a link to later on for you to
use it anywhere you want to thank you I
appreciate the opportunity to talk you
through okay thanks thanks again my sir
a nice day bye you do the same right